ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre sur notre antenne les premiers
pas de gérard longuet en tant que
ministre de la défense et des anciens
combattants gérard longuet vient
défendre devant ses anciens collègues
sénateurs deux projets de loi l'un
relatifs à la lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive
l'autre concernant l'importation et
l'exportation de matériel de guerre
il s'agit pour la france de transposer
des directives européennes pour mieux
encadrer la vente et le commerce d'armes
à l'étranger tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle du sénat très bel
après-midi à tous ses ministres
je suis heureuse de vous saluer dans vos
nouvelles fonctions
soyez bien lieu au sénat au banc des
ministres l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif à la lutte
contre la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive et de leurs vecteurs
dans la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur gérard longuet
ministre de la défense et des anciens
combattants
et
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il naturellement
j'avais la tentation de vous dire chers
collègues il se trouve que ce bonheur
mais privé pour quelques mois et je
voudrais m'exprimer à cet instant en
qualité de ministre de la défense pour
vous présenter le projet de loi relatif
à la lutte contre la prolifération des
armes de destruction massive et leurs
vecteurs l'aurait salué le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées cher
josselin de rohan je voudrais saluer le
rapporteur chaire andré dulait et vous
dire que ce projet de loi rassemble des
opinions unanime tant il est nécessaire
de mettre à jour notre législation pour
combattre utilement une prolifération
des armes de destruction massive qui
n'appartient pas au seul domaine de la
fiction ou de l'imagination mais bien
hélas des réalités ainsi qu'en
témoignent les observations du livre
blanc sur la défense et la sécurité
nationale paru en 2008 ainsi qu'en
témoigne par exemple dans l'actualité
récente
la mise à jour du réseau du scientifique
nucléaire pakistanaise abdul qadeer khan
et des révélations que la presse
diffusent au plan international sur par
exemple les pratiques de certains pays
on pense à la corée du nord là des
structures effondrement de l'empiré
soviétique et l'effondrement tout
particulier de son empire militaro
industriel dans ces décombres a laissé
émerger des formes nouvelles de
transactions illicites particulièrement
préoccupante
non seulement il s'agit d'armes de
destruction massive mais également des
biens à double usage qui dont un usage
civil reconnu et accepté mais qui peut
faire une application militaire doit
également
traite ce projet de loi traite également
des de la prolifération organisés par
des réseaux privés ou clandestins et non
pas seulement par des états tant
l'économie souterraine
aujourd'hui favorisé par la
libéralisation du commerce international
permet de faire à certains d'utiliser
malheureusement et contre l'intérêt
général
une maîtrise scientifique largement
diffusée dans le monde et parfois
d'ailleurs adossés à certains états dans
ce contexte les services de
renseignement souligne le risque de voir
des acteurs non étatiques cherchait à
acquérir des armes de destruction
massive alors la communauté
internationale a réagi les nations unies
le conseil de sécurité ont adopté les
résolutions 1540 et 1810 en 2004 et
ainsi qu'en 2008 il
elles font ces nations unies obligations
état d'améliorer leurs outils juridiques
afin de prendre en compte toutes les
dimensions de la lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive
qu'il s'agisse d'armes nucléaire
biologique chimique de leurs vecteurs et
des matériels connexes sans lesquels
évidemment ces armes ne pourrait pas
être utilisée
j'ajoute qu'une résolution 1887 du
conseil de sécurité en 2009 reconnaît la
nécessité pour tous les états d'adopter
des mesures efficaces pour empêcher que
des terroristes ne puissent accéder à
des matières nucléaires ou une
assistance technique
je dirais autour des matières nucléaires
la france avait demandé un diagnostic
interministériel il est
premier ministre avait commandés en
novembre 2006 ce diagnostic a mis en
évidence la complexité les carences le
manque de lisibilité de notre arsenal
juridique de lutte contre la
prolifération qui était flatté entre le
code de la défense le code des douanes
le code pénal le code de procédure
pénale et le projet de loi que ce
bonheur de vous présenter a pour objet
d'établir plus de cohérence plus
d'efficacité d'être faire en sorte que
les textes soient plus dissuasif pour
obtenir d'abord l'harmonisation des
dispositions relatives aux infractions
ainsi qu'aux peine encourue otites
d'actes de prolifération dans les trois
domaines nucléaires biologiques et
chimiques
car en l'état actuel la prolifération
chimique est la plus sévèrement
sanctionné ce qui est légitime mais
harmonisons les dispositions relatives
c'est le premier objectif de ce projet
de loi en matière d'infractions le
deuxième objectif de ce projet de loi
est d'introduire des dispositions
relatives aux vecteurs d'armes de
destruction massive avec une peine de 15
ans de réclusion criminelle
prévu pour les infractions relatives à
la fabrication commerce à l'acquisition
à la détention ou transport de ces
vecteurs d'armes
troisième élément de ce projet de loi le
renforcement des peines encourues en
matière de contrebande d'importation et
d'exportation de biens de technologies à
double usage
cette nouvelle infraction douanière
permettrait l'ouverture d' enquêtes
judiciaires favorisant le démantèlement
de filières de fraudes
j'ajoute enfin deux éléments combler une
lacune importante du dispositif
juridique en matière de financement car
le finance la lutte contre le privilégie
la répression du terrorisme et pas assez
ne pas jusqu'à présent le blanchiment au
détriment de la prolifération dernier
élément du projet de loi
le renforcement des moyens procéduraux
de lutte contre
prolifération sur le modèle qui fait ses
preuves dans notre pays des règles
applicables contre le terrorisme et la
criminalité organisée je pense tout
particulièrement à la centralisation des
enquêtes et des jugements du tribunal de
grande instance de paris et à
l'utilisation de techniques spéciales
denquête voilà l'objet de ce projet de
loi
ce projet de loi est examiné par votre
commission monsieur le président je
voudrais vous remercier chaleureusement
vous même personnellement et remercié le
rapporteur ainsi que l'ensemble des
membres de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées qui a adopté à l'unanimité en
commission monsieur le premier ministre
ce texte nous nous en réjouissons l'un
messieurs les sénateurs péroraison final
je voudrais vous dire que notre pays est
déjà parti aux instruments juridiques
internationaux comme le traité de non
prolifération nucléaire la convention
d'interdiction des armes chimiques le
règlement 428 2009 du conseil de l'union
européenne portant sur l'exportation le
transit le courtage des biens à double
usage
il s'est engagé de manière déterminée
pour renforcer l'efficacité de la
stratégie de l'union européenne en
matière de lutte contre la prolifération
en adoptant cette loi notre pays
franchira une étape supplémentaire
faisant preuve ainsi d'une exemplarité
accrue elle monta priorité qu'elle
accorde à la lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive achève le travail lancé dans le
cadre du g8 ce travail g8 en avait fait
une priorité
nous en sommes actuellement pour la
sixième fois le président de ce g8
en adoptant cette loi nous montrons que
nous sommes en effet déterminé entraîné
les grandes nations dans un effort
pertinent appliquée systématique de
lutte contre la prolifération et qui est
contre ceux qui la rendent possible
c'est un texte qui tient compte de la
réalité de la modernité
et je vous remercie d'avancé adopter
cette attitude de rassemblement que
votre commission a exprimé en votant ce
texte à l'unanimité
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur andré dulait
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées
monsieur madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre est cher collègue tout
d'abord monsieur le ministre
permettez moi étant le premier orateur
de cet après-midi de vous féliciter pour
les nouvelles fonctions que vous occupez
vous dire le plaisir que nous avons à
vous retrouver et nous savons combien
votre rôle devra être important dans les
mois et les semaines qui viennent
dans sa résolution 15,140 du 28 avril
2004 le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies a clairement désigné la
prolifération des armes nucléaires
chimiques et biologiques et de leurs
vecteurs comme une menace pour la paix
et la sécurité internationales cette
menace est directement liée au pouvoir
destructeur de ces armes qui justifie le
principe d'interdiction pardonner oui
la menace est également un direct car la
prolifération est un facteur de course
aux armements les de déstabilisation
dont plusieurs régions du monde
notamment en asie et au moyen-orient
la possession des missiles balistiques
ou de croisière par un nombre croissant
d'états ne fait qu'exacerber la
prolifération nucléaires chimiques ou
biologiques
aujourd'hui trente trois états n'ont
toujours pas ratifié la convention
d'interdiction des armes biologiques de
1972 cet état neuf sont pas parties à la
convention d'interdiction de 93 et trois
états n'ont pas adhéré au traité de non
prolifération nucléaire alors que la
corée du nord s'en est retirée en 2003
par ailleurs l'adhésion à ces
instruments fondamentaux n'en garantit
pas toujours le plein respect la
convention d'interdiction des armes
biologiques ne comporte pas en effet de
mécanismes d'inspection et de
vérification le contrôle de l'agencé
nationale internationale de l'énergie
atomique sur les activités nucléaires se
heurte à des limites politiques
juridiques et techniques c'est ce que
nous avons pu observer en iran enfin le
rôle croissant des acteurs non étatiques
dans la prolifération est un phénomène
marquant de ces quinze dernières années
chacun a en mémoire les activités du
réseau dirigé par le scientifique
nucléaire pakistanais qadeer khan la
diffusion des savoir faire scientifique
et des technologies
comme la mondialisation des échanges
favorisent l'apparition de nouveaux
acteurs de la prolifération qui
s'affranchissent largement des logiques
et des pratiques habituelles des états
face à ce type d'agissement le
renforcement des contrôles étatiques sur
la fabrication et les transfert
d'équipements sensibles est
indispensable c'est l'objet de la
résolution 15 40 qui est en grande
partie à l'origine du projet de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui la résolution
15/4 en prescrit aux états la mise en
oeuvre d'un véritable plan de lutte
contre les acteurs non étatiques de la
prolifération à cet effet elle demande
aux états de se doter d'une législation
interdisant et réprimandé activités
d'acteurs non étatiques liés aux armes
de destruction massive ou à leurs
vecteurs dans second lieu de mettre en
place des dispositifs intérieur de
contrôle visant à comptabiliser les
produits sensibles à assurer leur
protection physique et à surveiller les
exportations enfin d'empêcher le trafic
de ces armes de leurs vecteurs
la résolution a créé un comité auprès du
conseil de sécurité a appelé comité
15,140 qui est chargé d'en suivre la
mise en oeuvre ce comité analyse les
rapports sur les mesures d'application
nationale que les états membres sont
tenus de remettre régulièrement
la france a soutenu l'adoption de cette
résolution et se doit de la mettre en
oeuvre de manière aussi complète que
possible notre arsenal juridique en
matière de lutte contre la prolifération
des armes de destruction massive résulte
de strates successives comme vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le ministre
notamment notre adhésion à plusieurs
instruments internationaux les
convention d'interdiction des armes
biologiques et des armes chimiques
que nous avons déjà évoqué mais aussi la
convention à las higueras sur la
protection physique des matières
nucléaires
c'est pour rendre cette législation plus
complète et plus cohérente que le
présent projet de loi a été élaboré
parmi les améliorations apportées par ce
texte nous pouvons retenir les points
suivants tout d'abord le projet de loi
permet une harmonisation entre les
régimes des sanctions pénales
applicables aux armes chimiques
biologiques ou aux arts aux matières
nucléaires
il comble certaines lacunes notamment
l'absence d'incrimination du financement
des activités liées à la prolifération
comme cela existe par exemple pour le
terrorisme
il instaure un régime pénal spécifique
plus sévères pour les activités menées
en bande organisée ou dans le but avéré
de réaliser une arme
cela permettra de cibler plus
efficacement les réseaux de la
prolifération en les distinguant des
agissements isoler la seconde
amélioration résulte de l'introduction
en droit français à la notion de la
notion de vecteurs d'armes de
destruction massive
conformément à la résolution 15 40
jusqu'à présent ces engins n'était pas
distinguer des autres matériels de
guerre alors que les infractions les
concernant justifie un dispositif
particulier troisième point le projet de
loi renforce les sanctions en cas
d'infraction sur l'exportation des biens
et technologies à double usage
on sait qu'il s'agit là d'un canal
privilégié pour les réseaux de
prolifération car la vigilance des états
plus partie plus facilement prise en
défaut lorsqu'il s'agit d'un usage
double enfin le projet de loi instaure
des règles spécifiques de procédure
pénale notamment la centralisation des
poursuites et des juges
au tgi de paris afin de lutter plus
efficacement contre la prolifération
aux yeux de notre commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
ce projet de loi va nous doter d'un
dispositif très complet permettant de
réprimer sévèrement tous les actes en
lien avec la prolifération
fort heureusement nous n'avons jusqu'à
présent était que très peu confrontés à
ce type d'affaires une seule je pense a
été examiné il n'en demeure pas moins
nécessaire de mettre en place tous les
moyens juridiques nécessaires pour y
faire face
grâce à ce projet de loi la france sera
en conformité avec les obligations qui
découlent de la résolution 15 100 car en
étant rappelé que chaque état fait
l'objet d'un examen régulier par le
comité spécial institué auprès du
conseil de sécurité et nous semble
également qu'avec la mise en place d'une
législation complète et efficace
la france peut contribuer à promouvoir
auprès des autres états les meilleurs
standards et les meilleures pratiques
nous savons que sur ces questions de
prolifération
la france travaille étroitement avec ses
partenaires européens et que l'union
européenne est engagée en tant que tel
dans une stratégie de lutte contre la
prolifération
elle a notamment adopté une
réglementation sur les biens à double
usage civil et militaire destinée à
harmoniser les pratiques des états mans
l'europe consacre une grande partie des
technologies et des équipements
sensibles on regarde la prolifération il
est indispensable d'adopter une approche
coordonnée en la matière je souhaiterais
également raccorder une problématique
qui sort du champ propre du projet de
loi
il s'agit du risque d'utilisation
d'éléments radioactifs par exemple
d'origine
médical pour la fabrication de bombes
radiologiques que l'on appelle encore
les bombes sales au sens du projet de
loi nous sommes en dehors du texte mais
c'est une hypothèse qui peut être
utilisée pour le terrorisme de masse et
qu'il faut donc prendre en compte l'
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a adopté en 2003 un code de
conduite sur la sûreté et la sécurité
des sources radioactives
il incite fortement les états à protéger
les sources radioactives
les plus dangereuses contre les actes de
malveillance la mise en place d'un
dispositif de contrôle de la sécurité
des sources radioactives est nécessaire
je sais que des travaux
interministériels ont été engagées en ce
sens il ya un peu plus de deux ans il
nous paraît important que les mesures
législatives correspondante puisse
intervenir aussi rapidement que possible
pouvez vous nous donner monsieur le
ministre quelques indications sur ce
point pour conclure je dois indiquer que
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense a considéré que ce projet
de loi constituait une avancée positive
elle a adopté à l'unanimité et au nom de
la commission je vous demande donc mes
chers collègues d'approuver ce projet de
loi moulin dans le texte issu des débats
de l'assemblée nationale en vous priant
de bien vouloir excuser m'avoua
défaillante
merci à chaque collègue dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur jean pierre chevènement au
titre du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord monsieur mise permettez moi de
vous présenter mes cordiales
félicitations pour votre promotion
attendue
un poste prestigieux je suis certain que
de cette charge et de ses
responsabilités vous saurez vous
acquitter au mieux les intérêts de la
france et de nos forces armées
l'adoption du présent projet de loi
monsieur ministre mettra enfin la france
en conformité avec les obligations qui
découlent de la résolution 15,140 adopté
je le rappelle le 28 août 2004 par le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies on
peut se demander pourquoi il va lui près
de 70 ans à la france pour réaliser
cette mise en conformité
alors que dès la chute du régime taliban
en 2001
les services de renseignement américains
faisait savoir l'intérêt d'al qaïda pour
recueillir les éléments nécessaires à la
confection d'une arme nucléaire
on ne compte plus les nombreuses
initiatives internationales dont les
principales sont le partenariat mondial
du g8 de juin 2002 au sommet de
kananaskis ce évoquerait jan 2003
l'arraisonnement dans les eaux
italiennes du cargo allemand bbc china
transportant des centrifugeuses que la
libye à la suite de quoi la libye a
révélé les activités du réseau semi
privé du docteur abdel kader camp pour
approvisionner ses commanditaires à
travers de multiples ramifications en
matière nucléaire équipements mode
d'emploi permettant la réalisation une
finale une arme nucléaire je ne veux pas
évoquer l'initiative dite paix si
l'initiative de sécurité contre la
prolifération de mai 2003 la stratégie
européenne non prolifération de 2003 la
global slit rédaction initiative j'étais
riz
lancée en 2004 par les états unis en
liaison avec la ea dont le fonds de
sécurité nucléaire et alimenté je le
rappelle par les contributions
volontaires des états la global
initiative to come back the nuclear
terrorisme prise en 2006 par le
président bush et poutine
enfin le 5 avril 2009 dans son discours
de prague le président obama a qualifié
la menace de terrorisme nucléaire comme
étant la plus immédiate et la plus
extrême pour la sécurité du monde
en avril 2010 un sommet mondial sur la
sécurité nucléaire s'est tenu à
washington
il a permis de ratifier la convention
sur la protection physique des matières
nucléaires sont un amendement de 2005
met l'accent sur le recensement des
matières sensibles et d'encourager la
minimisation des usages civils de
l'uranium hautement enrichi
on peut donc s'étonner une chemise du
retard avec lequel ces projets de loi
vient devant le parlement
ce n'est qu'en novembre 2006 que le
premier ministre a confié au secrétariat
général de la défense nationale le soin
d'effectuer un diagnostic
interministériel sur l'ensemble de notre
arsenal juridique en matière de lutte
contre la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive et de leurs vecteurs
mieux vaut tard que jamais notre
législation actuelle résultait de
l'empilement de strates successives de
1972 2010 il est donc bon d'harmoniser
les dispositions régissant les trois
domaines nucléaire biologique chimique
en aggravant notamment les peines
frappant les activités menées en bande
organisée avant de dissuader les réseaux
étaient bond
réprimer le financement des actes
contribuent à la prolifération
il est également nécessaire de renforcer
et d'élargir le dispositif répressif
lier la prolifération on ne peut que se
réjouir de la centralisation des
poursuites et des jugements au tjp paris
sur le modèle éprouvé de la législation
antiterroriste
l'assemblée nationale a adopté à
l'unanimité le 25 novembre 2010 le
projet de loi votre commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et les
forces armées
nouveau buzz d'en faire autant sur le
rapport de notre collègue monsieur du
lait
je me bornerai ministre à faire quelques
observations tout d'abord ce projet de
loi sera utile notamment ce qu'il
définira un modèle pour d'autres pays d
un domaine dont on ne saurait
sous-estimer l'importance stratégique
deuxièmement doit pas se dissimuler que
la plupart des trafics se déroule hors
du territoire national
l'adoption de lois de donc être relayée
par une intense activité de coopération
internationale en matière de
renseignement et en tous domaines
policiers douaniers fiscale maritime
aérien
troisièmement on peut s'étonner 2002 aux
missions l'une relevé par monsieur du
lait concernant la confection de bombes
radiologiques dit encore bombes sales
dont le risque paraît plus élevé que
celui de la fabrication ou du vol d'une
arme nucléaire proprement dite dans la
mise en oeuvre par injectera pour
briller ne va pas de soi
notre rapporteur nous a dit que le
gouvernement préparer un projet de loi
sur la protection des sources
radioactives
je souhaite que vous indiquiez le délai
nécessaire au dépôt le projet de loi sur
le bureau des assemblées
de même aucune disposition n'est prévu
pour faire face aux attaques éventuelles
dans le cyber-espace ne serait-il pas
temps là aussi demandé au sgdn de faire
des propositions
quatrièmement enfin l'intérêt apporté la
lutte contre la prolifération
émanant d'acteurs données tactiques
données statiques ne doit pas nous
détourner de la lutte contre la
prolifération
d'origine étatique tant il est vrai que
le trafic illicite se nourrissent des
comportements proliférant d'état n'ayant
pas souscrit au tnp ou à d'autres astres
man juridiques internationaux ou ne se
conformant pas à leurs obligations
ainsi 33 états n'ont toujours pas
ratifié la convention d'interdiction des
armes biologiques 7 ne sont pas parties
à la convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques dans les deux cas il ya la
syrie l'egypte israël
la convention d'interdiction des armes
biologiques souffre de l'absence d'un
mécanisme d'inspection et de
vérification
quelles initiatives comptez vous prendre
pour y remédier enfin la prolifération
balistique ne peut être enrayée à
travers le régime de contrôle était
d'oenologie missile aim tcr créée en
1987 ni par le code de conduite de l'est
de novembre 2002 qui n'est pas
contraignant
que comptez vous faire
notons enfin que le projet de traité dit
que turf interdisant la production de
matière fissile à usage militaire est en
panne du fait du veto pakistanais à la
conférence du désarmement et du refus
par la chine de tout moratoire sur la
production de ces matières quelles
initiatives le gomme en français quand
il prend dans ce domaine qui fonde la
crédibilité de la lutte contre la
prolifération
notons en dernier lieu que
l'administration américaine sont pas en
mesure de faire ratifier le traité
d'interdiction des essais nucléaires par
le sénat américain
faute de la majorité des deux tiers
nécessaire à cet effet discours de
prague à la réalité il y a un écart
auquel je rends sensible la
représentation nationale la lutte contre
la prolifération est un tout on aimerait
que le gouvernement nous donne une vue
d'ensemble de la manière dont il voit
l'application des résolutions de la
conférence d'examen du tnp de mai 2010
dans ces domaines complexes la vigilance
ne doit jamais se relaxer il vaudrait
mieux monsieur le ministre que le
gouvernement soit critiquée pour son
activisme plutôt que pour sa mollesse
ces réserves le groupe rdse votera le
projet de loi merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame michelle
demessine pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs du parti
de gauche
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
après avoir suivi heure par heure ce
week-end de chaises musicales
je voudrais saluer l'arrivée d'anne nos
collègues à cette responsabilité
régalienne au plus haut niveau de l'état
il nous en féliciter monsieur le
ministre
conformément à la résolution 1540 du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies du
28 avril 2004 ce projet de loi consiste
à mettre en place des dispositifs
permettant dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive de leurs vecteurs et
des matériels connexes d'agir contre les
trafics illicites et les acteurs non
étatiques
ce texte prévoit de créer une procédure
spécifique pour les infractions
contribuant la prolifération déjà des
armes de destruction massive
centralisation de l'enquète de la
poursuite de l'instruction et du
jugement des crimes et délits au tgi de
paris ainsi qu'un allongement
substantielle des délais de prescription
pour s'aligner sur ceux du terrorisme il
crée une incrimination du financement
des actes contribuant à la prolifération
ainsi qu'une aggravation des peines
encourues enfin il renforce le contrôle
des biens à double usage
c'est à dire civils et militaires si on
ne saurait prendre le risque de laisser
tomber entre les mains des terroristes
ces armes capables de mettre en danger
la sécurité du monde
il ne faut pas se leurrer sur la portée
réelle d'un tel texte jusque là un seul
faits a été jugé en france concernant
l'exportation la fabrication ou
l'utilisation illégale d'armes de
destruction massive
c'était en 2003 lorsque le tribunal
correctionnel de paris a prononcé des
peines allant de dix mois à trois ans de
prison à l'encontre de trois personnes
arrêtées sur le territoire français
en pause il en possession d'uranium
hautement enrichi
ainsi de l'avis de tous la prolifération
d'armes de destruction massive sur notre
territoire est peu probable
le problème vient d'ailleurs puisque les
terroristes ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières et que des attaques peuvent
venir de l'autre bout du monde dans des
états qui ne sont pas en mesure de
lutter contre ce type de prolifération
d'armes de destruction massive malgré
les mesures d'être que prévoit la
résolution 1540 des nations unies
néanmoins nul ne saurait être pour que
la prolifération de ces matières
extrêmement dangereuse au profit de
terrorisme passe par la france on ne
saurait transiger avec un tel enjeu on
n'aura de cesse de le répéter
suffisamment ces armes peuvent en une
seule fois tué des centaines de milliers
de personnes
cependant ce projet de loi ne saurait
être éclipsé le problème central sur
lesquels je voudrais mais tendre un peu
la principale source d'insécurité pour
notre planète vient des états eux-mêmes
qui rentre à reculons sur le chemin du
désarmement n'est nucléaire pour les
états dotés de l'armé nucléaire et celui
de et sur celui de la non prolifération
pour les autres le développement de
nouvelles forces nucléaires élève le
niveau de la menace attentionnel et
augmente la probabilité des risques de
risques accidentels comme celui du
détournement des armes
ce texte s'attaque à la prolifération
illégal mais quand bien même celle là
est légal elle constitue un risque pour
la sécurité internationale dont nous
partageons la responsabilité avec
l'ensemble du monde pour sa part notre
pays fait malheureusement fausse route
en se considérant comme un bon élève et
que l'arrêt des essais nucléaires et la
limitation de son arsenal à 300 ogives
nucléaires
dispenserait de tout nouvel effort on ne
compte plus les occasions manquées par
le gouvernement
en de s'engager sur le sur le chemin du
désarmement nucléaire depuis quelques
années malheureusement il est loin de
briller par son volontarisme en la
matière avec comme trame de fond la
conviction que cela coïnciderait avec un
déclassement de la puissance de la
france dans le concert des nations
ainsi en mai dernier à la tribune des
nations unies lors de la conférence de
révision du tnp
la france a réitéré son discours
habituel sont la non prolifération
nucléaire bien que cette obstination
d'épisodes nucléaire provoqué l'échec
complet de la précédente conférence
d'examen en 2005 la france et resterez
est resté prostré sur ses positions
participant a transformé en marché de
dupes le fondement du tnp qui impose de
pays n'ayant pas encore testé d'engins
nucléaires de ne pas mettre de ne pas en
mettre au point
lorsqu en échange les pays détenteurs
s'engage au désarmement nucléaire le
gouvernement interprète même de façon
spécieuse tnp en ayant installé en
gironde
le laser mégajoule cet outil destiné à
simuler les explosions nucléaires
militaires et opérationnel en 2014 a un
coût pour le contribuable à hauteur de
2,3 milliards d'euros sur dix ans alors
qu ailleurs le gouvernement impose
toujours des économies draconiennes sur
la plupart des budgets sociaux
nous déplorons les développements de ce
programme tout comme la construction du
centre de simulation des armes
nucléaires conclut conclu le 2 novembre
dernier entre nicolas sarkozy et david
cameron lors de la signature des deux
traités de coopération militaire par
ailleurs je profite aujourd'hui du vote
de ce projet de loi pour réitérer une
proposition que j'avais déjà formulées
devant cette même assemblée le 23 mars
dernier lors du débat sur le désarmement
et la non prolifération et la sécurité
de la france c'est-à-dire l'arrêt du
programme de missile stratégique m51 qui
contient des têtes nucléaires
et est un héritage de la guerre froide
plus qu'un instrument de défense adaptés
aux menaces qui pèsent aujourd'hui sur
notre sécurité
en outre le gouvernement et le président
de la république sont attentistes dans
la dynamique de désarmement nucléaire en
cours sur la planète puisqu'il refuse
toujours de soutenir la convention
d'élimination des armes nucléaires
signer par 75% des états du monde
nous allions dr d'ailleurs déposé notre
groupe une proposition des résulats de
résolution en ce sens quant au dernier
sommet de l'otan des 19 et 20 novembre
dernier qui a en tout entre autres
entériné une défense anti-missile
coûteuse et marcamps l'abandon de
l'ambition d'une défense européenne
le président de la république il ya
encore montré des réticences dans la
perspective d'un monde débarrassé des
armes nucléaires
il a fait peser tout le poids de la
france contre le clan le camp pardon des
anti nucléaires menés par l'allemagne
pour que soit réinscrit la vocation
nucléaires de l'otan dans la stratégie
de lisbonne en y faisant introduire la
phrase que je cite
tant qu'il y aura des armes nucléaires
l'otan demeurera une puissance nucléaire
insisté pour baser le lien
transatlantique sur la question
nucléaire est contradictoire avec notre
conception originelle de l'armé
nucléaire comme garante de
l'indépendance française
la puissance de notre pays est à présent
considéré par le président de notre de
la république et son gouvernement comme
la capacité d'être au plus près possible
du rayonnement américain tout cela
ternit l'image de la france et la prive
d'une réelle crédibilité internationale
bien entendu ces aspects dépasse le
cadre de la discussion mais il était
impossible de ne pas les aborder
pour ne pas contourner les problèmes
cruciaux que pose ce projet de loi est
donc pour en revenir au texte lui même
par application de la légalité
internationale et parce qu'on ne saurait
transiger avec un terrorisme qui
sévirait abbas d'armes de destruction
massive
vous l'aurez compris nous voterons
contre pour ce texte
merci ma chère collègue la parole et à
monsieur rachel mazuir
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur mise chers
collègues toutes mes félicitations je me
joins aux félicitations précédente
je me réjouis personnellement de nous
nous réjouissons personnellement de en
ce qui me concerne de l'arrivée de ce
texte au sénat qui je l'espère restera
d'application hypothétique
autrement dit que nous n'aurons jamais à
connaître de faits criminels les plus
graves commandités ou encouragé par des
groupuscules au moyen d'armes de
destruction massive
je salue l'adoption de ce texte à
l'unanimité par les députés mais aussi
par la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat qui n'a apporté
aucune modification l'issue de son
examen au sénat devrait être tout autant
favorable et je souhaite vivement que
cette initiative soit pleinement suivie
par les autres pays signataires de la
résolution 15,140 du conseil sécurité de
l'onu à l'origine de cette
réglementation pour autant même si je ne
saurait remettre en cause le bien fondé
ce démarche internationale je doute
néanmoins de son efficacité et je
souhaite vous exprimés ci-après mes
doutes et mes remarques l'historique du
projet je ne pas reprendre et analyser
l'ensemble des articles ça a été fait
brillamment par mais ceux qui sont
intervenus
l'ensemble des intervenants est si
présent mais je vais revenir sur
l'historique de cette initiative évoquée
par certains ce projet de loi a pour
objet de transposer en droit national
les décisions contenues dans la
résolution 440 du conseil sécurité de
l'onu adoptée à l'unanimité le 28 avril
lesquels ont pour objet d'interdire aux
états d'aider les acteurs non étatiques
à se procurer les moyens et les
techniques scientifiques permettant de
se doter d'armes nucléaires biologiques
et chimiques juridiquement contraignante
cette résolution impose un changement de
législation interne des états membres
qui souhaitent s'y confirme conformer
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
je souhaite tout à foug toutefois poussé
ce rétrospective historique plus loin en
exposant d'autres facteurs qui ont ainsi
encourager les états à légiférer contre
ce fléau
les faits remontent au 10 décembre 2002
lors de l'arraisonnement par la marine
espagnole sur ordre des forces
américaines du navire nord coréen
sociale qui se trouvait dans les eaux
internationales à destination du yémen
l'absence de textes juridiques
appropriés n'avait pas permis la saisie
de pièces de missiles balistiques dont
la provenance quasi certaine de corée du
nord n'avait pu être prouvée à la suite
de cette constatation de l'impuissance
des grandes forces de ce monde à lutter
contre la prolifération de telles armes
c'est le président américain dont george
bush qui le 31 mai 2003 l'ancien grand
programme de coopération internationale
le psi bien connu initiatives de
sécurité en matière de prolifération
dans le but d'enrayer ce trafic d armes
de destruction massive dès 2003
septembre ce sont onze pays dont la
france qui ont adopté et publié cette
déclaration sur les principes
d'interdiction de la psi mais la paix
ici n'est ni une institution ni une
organisation
la participation à la coopération se
font sur la base du volontariat
et je rappelle que la russie et la chine
ne faisait pas partie en parallèle la
france et d'autres états membres
européens s'étaient déjà réunis sur ce
thème lors du conseil européen de
thessalonique du 19 au 20 juin 2003 à
cette occasion il avait adopté une
déclaration sur la non prolifération
dans laquelle ils s'étaient engagés à
poursuivre l'élaboration d'une stratégie
communautaire cohérente visant à faire
face à la menace d adn
cette stratégie européenne a même été
récemment complété en décembre 2008 sous
présidence française a été dit par un
plan d'action contre la prolifération
des armes dites nrbc nucléaire
radiologique biologique et chimique qui
couvre ainsi tous les volets de la lutte
contre la prolifération
mais
à ce sujet monsieur le ministre il
serait sans doute intéressant de nous
voir présenter un bilan de ce plan
d'action européen et c'est pour
compléter ce dispositif donc que la
résolution 15 140 en effet été prises
également l'initiative du président
américain lors d'une réunion du conseil
de sécurité dont j'avais dit quelques
mois après le la mise en place de la psi
quelles limites car il y en a à la
résolution 15,140 certains sont
interrogés sur l'utilité de voter cette
résolution alors même que la pays s'ils
venaient d'être entreprise par la
plupart des grands pays de ce monde
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui les résultats
obtenus peuvent paraître modestes
le deuxième rapport du comité 15,140
souligne en effet que tous les pays ne
traite pas de la même manière ce
problème alors même que l'objectif de
ces dispositions préconisées une
réaction unanime est similaire de
l'ensemble des états adhérents à ce
titre
j'ose espérer que le mandat de ce comité
15,140 créé par la résolution auprès du
conseil sécurité est chargé d'en
examiner la mise en oeuvre sera de
nouveau renouvelé en à son expiration en
avril 2011 c'est bientôt
il est indispensable de maintenir ce
dispositif est de veiller à la bonne
application de ces dispositions par les
états membres en comparaison nous mêmes
ce sont plus de 90 pays qui à ce jour
ont souscrit au principe d'un pays si
doit-on justifier cet engouement par le
quai caractère non-contraignant
contraignant je rappelle de cette
initiative initiative qui peut
apparaître comme le signe d'un
engagement politique
quelque peu informel de surcroît et
contrairement à la résolution 100-112
qui demandait au pakistan et à l'inde
d'adhérer au traité de non prolifération
nucléaire
cette résolution 15,140 s'est abstenu
d'exiger bien évidemment une telle
adhésion
cette résolution ne vise en outre la
prolifération nucléaire que par la
mention des acteurs non étatiques
lesquels ne sont d'ailleurs qu'un
parfaitement définis alors je cite
personne ou entité qui n'agissant pas
sous l'autorité légale d'un état même
des activités tombant sur le coût de la
présente résolution
c'est relativement vague j'espère que ce
sera quand même efficace
les états ne sont donc pas concernés
bien que leurs responsabilités ou leur
négligence pourrait être invoquée je
pense comme beaucoup d'entre vous
j'imagine à la corée ou à l'iran cette
résolution visant principalement les
groupes terroristes une notion qui n'est
pourtant pas définies par le droit
international
et pour cause de plus cette résolution
ne résout en rien l'ex inspecteur des
navires en haute mer alors même que la
sphère du navire et soussane pointait ce
manque de juridique le droit de la mer
et vous le savez interdit à tout état de
contrôler sans traité bilatéral
les navires battant pavillon d'un autre
état en haute mer il aurait sans doute
fallu insérer une clause spéciale
autorisant ses interventions cependant
au travers des dispositions que ce
projet de loi de ce projet de loi la
france a ainsi choisi de renforcer sa
gestation en adoptant une procédure
pénale proches de celles prévues en
matière de terrorisme en prévoyant de
lourdes peines et en renforçant les
moyens d'investigation des forces de
l'ordre et des magistrats
comme il est impossible de se protéger
efficacement de toutes ses armes
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
primordial d'agir en amont et de veiller
bien évidemment à leur non prolifération
toutefois je m'interroge sur l'ailé les
raisons du dépôt tardif de ce texte jean
pierre chevènement l'a rappelé et à
leurs sept ans après l'adoption de cette
résolution
je n'ose doutait la moindre seconde que
l'urgence à vouloir transposer
soudainement cette réglementation dans
notre droit interne ne s'explique par
quelques menaces sous jacent
d'organisation licite trafiquante ou
d'aller nous rassurer j'en suis persuadé
monsieur le ministre
certains jugeront mon analyse pessimiste
mais il m'est apparu utile de soulever
ces questions légitimes au regard de
l'importance du thème traité aujourd'hui
ce projet de loi est encourageant et a
le mérite de dresser une ligne directe
ce qui peut être suivie et reprise ça a
été dit et c'est important par des pays
tiers
il renforce nos propres moyens d'action
par le développement de mesures pénales
appropriées
serons-nous pour autant entendu qu'elle
est alors notre légitimité acclamé comme
la plupart des grandes puissances
nucléaires rechercher la paix et la
sécurité dans un monde sans armes
nucléaires
mais en parallèle rappeler et je
reprends le discours du président
américain prononcé à prague en 2009
ne vous méprenez pas tant que ces armes
existeront nous conserverons un national
sûr et efficace pour dissuader tout
adversaire tous les pays pour s est
ainsi tenir le même raisonnement héron
rentre alors dans un cercle vicieux où
la loi du plus fort s'applique et où la
force dissuasive rest une arme de guerre
menaçante et redoutable mes chers
collègues le chemin à parcourir est
encore long mais en votant ce texte nous
faisons aujourd'hui un pas important
merci chers collègues la parole est à
messieurs xavier pintât au titre de
l'union pour un mouvement populaire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre de la défense mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues
permettez moi de me réjouir doublement
cet après midi tout d'abord je voudrais
moi aussi salué l'arrivée de gérard
longuet à la tête de ce grand ministère
je sais son respect pour les hommes et
les femmes qui composent le ministère de
la défense ainsi que son profond
attachement aux valeurs qu'incarne cette
grande institution de la république donc
je souhaitais dû formuler tous mes voeux
amicaux de réussite
ensuite je voudrais me féliciter de
l'inscription rapide de ce projet de loi
notre ordre du jour à peine plus de
trois mois après son adoption à
l'assemblée nationale le 25 novembre
dernier
j'en profiterai également pour rendre
hommage au travail de notre collègue et
rapporteur andré du lait qui de la lutte
contre la piraterie à celle contre la
prolifération d'armes de destruction
massive ne cesse de s'atteler pour la
sécurité mondiale
enfin rappelons que des gens 2004 notre
commission s'était saisie d'une partie
de ce sujet je pense sous le contrôle du
président josselin de rohan un rapport
d'information sur la prolifération
nucléaire et les réponses aux crises en
la matière avaient été publiés cela
témoigne je crois non seulement de la
continuité du travail de notre
commission mais aussi de la qualité du
travail réalisé par cette commission le
projet de loi relatif à la lutte contre
la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive répondent à des
impératifs internationaux et nationaux
il ya encore peu l'interdiction des
armes de destruction massive était
appréhendée de façon catégorielles le
droit international successivement érigé
des conventions de plusieurs types d
convention d'interdiction pour les
domaines du biologique et du chimiques
telles que la convention d'avril 4,72
interdisant la mise au point la
fabrication et de stockage des armes
biologiques ou à base de toxine ou
encore celle de 93 interdisant la mise
au point la fabrication de stockage et
l'emploi des armes chimiques en
instaurant leur destruction
en outre pour les interdictions
protection dans les domaines du
nucléaire et des matériels à double
usage
ce sont des régimes de contrôle qui ont
été instituées j'en veux pour exemple la
convention de la haye a relative à la
protection physique des matières
nucléaires de 1979 avant l'effondrement
du bloc soviétique la menace que
représentaient les armes des actions
massives étaient étatiques et par
conséquent par conséquent clairement
identifiable d'ailleurs ce sont beaucoup
de doctrine qui ont vu le jour à cette
époque qui occupe aussi beaucoup de
chercheurs aujourd'hui en géopolitique
après 91 à la menace des armes de
destruction massive s'est ajoutée celle
de leur prolifération sauvage en dehors
de tout cadre juridique international
les trente dernières années et en
particulier les dix qui viennent de
s'écouler ont vu se mettre en place
l'émergence non seulement de nouveaux
états mais surtout de réseaux privés
clandestins internationaux à un moment
où le terrorisme a valeur de doctrine
stratégique pour les organisations non
étatiques en 2004 temps pour le groupe
des cinq pays détenteurs de l'armé
nucléaire que pour tous les pays à
ratifier les conventions évoqués ou
étant parti pris du traité de non
prolifération tnp faut bien avouer que
le choc est venu du pakistan
là les confessions du père de la bombe
nucléaire pakistanaise sur un réseau
organisé
les révélations de la libye sur ce même
réseau
on démontre l ampleur des ramifications
de la complexité du phénomène ces
nouveaux canaux de prolifération demeure
l'une des plus grandes menaces pour la
sécurité internationale
c'est face à leur étendue et à la très
difficile
reconstitution que le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu a adopté la résolution
15 40 et mis en place un comité avec un
groupe d'experts qui veille à son
application
d'ailleurs à cet instant je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur la
prorogation du mandat du comité après le
25 avril 2011 au vu je crois de la
multiplication des menaces actuelles
pour la sécurité internationale
il serait plus que souhaitable que notre
diplomatie s'emploie avec que ses
partenaires du conseil de sécurité à
définir les contours d'une nouvelle
résolution qui prolongera le mandat du
comité
15 40 par ailleurs il semble important
de rappeler que la résolution 15 40 et
garant d'une approche globale de la
lutte contre la prolifération d'armes de
destruction massive en premier lieu
celle ci vise à renforcer les contrôles
étatiques sur la fabrication les
transferts de biens et de technologies
considérées comme sensibles du point de
vue de la prolifération
en second lieu je crois que c'est parti
comme important elle enjoint les et à
adapter leurs dispositifs législatifs et
juridiques nationaux et de mettre en
place les systèmes de contrôle c'est
dans cette logique que s'inscrit le
texte de cet après midi en adoptant ce
texte la france membre du conseil de
sécurité la france état nucléaire y
souscrit activement pour notre pays ce
texte doit être envisagé comme je crois
une occasion d'avoir une occasion
adressé un message symbolique fort
tenant en respect à l'application de ses
engagements internationaux
ensuite aussi l'occasion d'ouvrir la
voie dans l'établissement de standards
législatif en matière de lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive en cela et même de façon
indirecte
la france répond aux obligations de la
résolution 15-40 relative à l'aide et
l'assistance aux autres pays qui n'ont
pas les capacités d'adaptation de leur
disque de leurs dispositifs législatifs
nationaux
mes chers collègues en plus honorer nos
obligations internationales
ce projet de loi est un formidable moyen
de pallier les lacunes notre législation
relative à la lutte contre la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive en effet l'arsenal législatif et
juridique actuel est trop morcelé
notre approche législative et répressive
du sujet est trop catégorielles elle
répond au classement d'armes des traités
internationaux les régissant le droit
actuel résulte de l'amputation de
ratification sucessives par notre pays
des conventions
d'ailleurs cette faille n'a pas manqué
d'être évoquée lors de l'élaboration du
livre blanc sur la défense la sécurité
nationale en 2008
l'heure est donc venue de procéder à une
harmonisation de la lutte contre la
prolifération d'armes de destruction
massive et de leurs vecteurs et ce dans
les trois domaines
ce projet de loi contient une
disposition je crois qu'il est
primordial
il introduit pour la première fois dans
notre législation la notion de vecteurs
sachant qu'auparavant ils n'étaient pas
distingue des autres matériels de guerre
et cela semble être une nécessité
absolue que de le faire ce ne
reviendrait pas sur le détail des
dispositions liées aux règles de
procédure pénale spécifique que le texte
instaure toutefois on peut que se
féliciter que ce projet aggrave les
sanctions prévues en cas d'exportation
sans déclaration de biens à double usage
ainsi le permettra de qualifier les
infractions les plus graves liés à la
prolifération d'actes terroristes
à mon sens ce sont là des avancées
majeures qui prennent en compte les
réalités stratégiques auxquels doit
faire face la france et pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe ump votera ce texte
pour conclure monsieur le ministre je
tenais aussi à rappeler que ce projet de
loi permet également notre pays de jouer
un rôle de leader au sein de l'union
européenne qui il faut bien l'avouer
dans ce domaine ne mène pas
une politique concertée l'harmonisation
des instruments juridiques français je
crois doit appeler à la mise en place de
meilleurs standards pratique européens
en matière de contrôle et de lutte
contre la prolifération d'armes de
destruction massive cela est capital car
le sol européen concentrent les
technologies les plus avancées
les équipements les plus sensibles et
qui peuvent faire l'objet bien entendu
de prolifération aussi je formulerai le
voeu que l'union européenne adopte
rapidement une politique plus coordonnée
contre la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive et de leurs vecteurs
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie merci sa collègue
la parole est à monsieur jacques berthou
apparenté au groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
chez mini surveillants n'est pas sous
toutes les félicitations qui vous ont
été adressées
je les partage comme le dit le fameux
proverbe mieux vaut tard que jamais car
il n'aura échappé à aucun observateur
que plusieurs années se sont écoulées
depuis l'adoption de la région
résolution 15,140 du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies en 2004 le projet de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
transposant notre droit interne les
décisions contenues dans cette
résolution
il a été déposé en 2009 soit cinq en
cinq ans après la rédaction de cette
résolution alors même que la france fut
l'un des pays à l'origine de son
adoption
ce texte a été adopté à l'unanimité à
l'assemblée nationale le 25 novembre
2010 dès son préambule cette résolution
rappeler certains principes principe
intangible la prolifération des armes
nucléaires biologiques ou chimiques
les fameuses nbc et de leurs vecteurs
constitue une menace pour la paix et la
sécurité internationales les états se
sont engagés à lutter contre cette
prolifération
l'une des principales préoccupations est
alors d'empêcher ou pour le moins de
rendre très difficile pour des acteurs
non étatiques donc des groupes
terroristes de se procurer des armes
nucléaires biologiques et chimiques
il s'agit il s'agit alors bien
évidemment de stigmatiser la menace
terroriste et d' essayer de la contenir
en adoptant des législations de principe
dans chaque état la résolution invite
ainsi l'ensemble des états à appliquer
adopté des législations appropriées
interdisant à tout acteur non étatique
de fabriquer ou de se procurer des armes
nucléaires biologiques ou chimiques
en 2004 cette résolution des nations
unies trouvait son origine dans un
contexte mondial particulièrement
brûlant trois ans après les attentats du
11 septembre et 13 mois après l'invasion
de l'irak par la coalition menée par les
états unis
nous sommes désormais en 2011 et les
temps ont changé
cependant il est de notre devoir
d'adopter
projet de loi d'autant plus que le
comité chargé de suivre la mise en
oeuvre de la résolution 15,140 devra
rendre au plus tard le 24 avril prochain
un rapport indiquant si la résolution
est est appliquée et ses prescriptions
satisfaites
il faut bien avouer qu'un
dysfonctionnement de transposition en
droit français ferait désordre
ce projet de loi est complexe sur le
fond mais il peut finalement être résumé
en quelques mots il s'agit simplement
d'interdire et de réprimer en droit
interne tout ce qui concourt de près ou
de loin à la prolifération d'armes
nucléaires biologiques et chimiques au
préfet au profit d'acteurs non étatiques
est également inclus dans ce champ toute
activité visant à permettre à un groupe
terroriste de se doter de vecteurs
c'est-à-dire de missiles ailleurs ce
projet de loi définit de manière très
large
les infractions relatives à la
prolifération des armes nbc et prévoit
des peines très lourdes
la procédure pénale est la même que
celle applicable en matière de
terrorisme
en optant ce projet de loi nous
répondons à une exigence des nations
unies bien sûr mais nous en voyons
également un signal dissuasif à tous
ceux qui tenteraient de s'impliquer dans
des activités de prolifération sur le
sol national
monsieur le ministre je vous assure
personne au sein du groupe socialiste et
apparentés ne saurait s'opposer à
l'adapter à la ddt d'adoption pardon de
ce projet de loi
d'ailleurs dans notre pays à l'exception
des terroristes même quel citoyen pour
et rationnellement être en faveur de la
prolifération des armes nucléaires
biologiques et chimiques au profit de
groupes terroristes
la france se doit d'adopter ces mesures
enfin 10 est de montrer sa détermination
à la matière ce texte est principalement
préventif
il n'a pas vocation souhaitons le à
s'appliquer au quotidien en réprimant
des infractions commises en matière de
prolifération d'armes et de baisser sur
le territoire national ce texte ne
saurait s'appliquer à priori qu'à des
tentatives isolées peut organiser un
terrorisme que l'on pourrait qualifier
d' amateur ce texte empêchera pas les
autres les groupes organisés de passer
les frontières et de sévir depuis
l'étranger il est en effet nécessaire
d'avoir en la matière une approche tous
azimuts
transfrontalière l'union européenne a
adopté en 2008 un plan d'action contre
la prolifération des armes dites nbc que
le parlement européen dans son rapport
de novembre 2010 a jugé manqué de
rigueur et de cohérence sur différents
points
on peut notamment regretté que la clause
de solidarité présente dans le traité de
lisbonne ne soit pas cité dans ce plan
d'action
la lutte contre la prolifération des
armes de destruction massive a longtemps
été un tabou
les politiques menées jusqu'à présent
semble s'essouffler par manque de
volontarisme
il est donc primordial que la france
réaffirme sa volonté d'action en matière
de lutte contre cette prolifération
puisque chacun est d'accord sur
l'adoption de ce texte enfin je le pense
force est de constater que les problèmes
de fond subsistent
nous légiférons aujourd'hui contre une
police fération parfaitement
hypothétique par l'adoption de ce projet
de loi nous nous protégeons en indochine
un danger qui reste jusqu'ici abstrait
la menace du terrorisme nucléaire est
hypothétique disait le risque
d'utilisation d'armes biologiques ou
chimiques par des groupes terroristes et
en revanche réel mais de telles armes ne
sont pas faciles à manipuler le constat
est partagé
rares sont les acteurs non étatiques les
groupes terroristes essayant de
développer des armes de destruction
massive
reconnaissons que le procédé est
complexe long à mettre en oeuvre
en bref il ne correspond aucunement aux
objectifs généralement recherché par les
groupes terroristes
ces derniers préfèrent agir vite en
employant des maths des méthodes simples
ingénieuse nécessitant une logistique
qui ne s'appuie pas sur les armes nbc
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 en
sont le meilleur exemple il suffit de
regarder la liste des attentats commis
dans les 15 dernières années pour s'en
convaincre les terroristes préfère
employer des méthodes traditionnelles
à côté de ça se souvient temps d
attentat au gaz sarin dans le métro de
tokyo en mars 95 qui faisait 12 morts et
des milliers de blessés
ou encore plus récemment de l'envoi de
bactéries de maladie du charbon par
courrier qui aurait coûté la vie de cinq
personnes aux états unis en 2001
enfin il me paraît indispensable de ne
pas dire un mot sur la prolifération des
tas ait à ce qui reste à ce jour la
principale menace en matière de
prolifération nucléaire
à ce titre je me souviens du débat que
nous avions eues ici même le 23 mars
dernier
un débat sur le désarmement la non
prolifération nucléaire et la sécurité
de la france l'excellent travail du
rapporteur monsieur jean pierre
chevènement démontré que le maintien de
notre posture et par conséquent de notre
effort de défense en matière de
dissuation constituait la meilleure
garantie de la paix la dissuasion est
bel et bien la seule garantie qui nous
est offerte contre la prolifération
d'état et a aucune législation nationale
ne pourrait éliminer un risque
quelconque cette prolifération la reste
principale menace le terrorisme ces
armes traditionnelles bien sûr il ne
faut pas sous-estimer la menace visés
par ce projet de loi de même qu'il ne
faut pas là surévaluée il faut donc
adopter ce projet de loi pour deux
bonnes raisons
ce texte nécessaire et il est conforme à
la résolution internationale que nous
avons adoptée en 2004
espérons que les juges n'est pas n'est
jamais appliqué ces dispositions sur
notre territoire
merci la parole et à madame dominique
voynet rattaché au groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le ministre on vous a ici
aujourd'hui chaudement félicité sur tous
les bancs à droite et pratiquement
autant à gauche c'est une tradition
républicaine
bienvenue mais vous me permettrez de
souligner l'étrangeté qui consiste pour
un pays comme le nôtre qui entend peser
sur la marche du monde et qui est doté
de robuste moyenne défense changer de
ministre de la défense à tout bout de
champ ainsi ce ne sont pas moins de
trois ministres de la défense qui auront
eu à se pencher sur ce petit texte qui
vise à adapter notre législation
nationale aux exigences de la résolution
1810 adopté en adapter en 2008 un texte
qui renforce donc notre arsenal
juridique de lutte contre la
prolifération des armements de
destruction massive et de leurs vecteurs
dans son préambule la résolution des
nations unies précise bien qu'il s'agit
d'interdire aux états d'aider des
acteurs non étatiques à se procurer des
moyens et techniques permettant de se
doter d'un nucléaires biologiques et
chimiques
la résolution réaffirme nous rappelle
des points sur lesquels nous serons tous
d'accord la prolifération des armes
nucléaires chimiques ou biologiques et
de leurs vecteurs constitue une menace
pour la paix et la sécurité
internationales les états se sont
engagés à lutter contre la prolifération
la menace terroriste est fort
préoccupante et parmi les préoccupations
principales figures le risque de voir
des acteurs non étatiques se procurer
des armes de destruction massive des
catégories citées le texte de loi qui
nous est proposé à skis donc dans le
droit national que tout ce qui concourt
d'une façon ou d'une autre de près ou de
loin à la prolifération d'armes
nucléaires biologiques ou à base de
toxine au profit d'acteurs non
gouvernementaux de groupes terroristes
est interdit et réprimé par la loi
il sait verizon les peines encourues par
les criminels et va jusqu'à prévoir
anecdotes ou cerise sur le gâteau la
confiscation des matériels
ou missile il également détenus je ne
doute pas que ce texte sera voté à
l'unanimité il le sera aussi par les
sénateurs verts mais je veux simplement
à cet instant poser une question à quoi
donc sert réellement ce texte
serons-nous désormais mieux protégés les
mesures annoncées sont elles de nature à
dissuader les criminels
en vérité je n'en suis pas certaine
même si vous nous dites qu'il se crée
une économie de la prolifération
illégale sur fond de mondialisation
utilisant les nouvelles technologies de
la communication et profitant de
l'ouverture des marchés financiers je ne
suis pas certaine même si vous nous
dites que des acteurs non étatiques
cherche très concrètement à acquérir des
armes de destruction massive ou des
composants permettant d'en fabriquer le
risque existe sans doute il est
essentiellement potentiel mais la
question reste entière
le projet de loi peut-il dissuader les
terroristes les trafiquants
les faits incriminés n'existe
pratiquement pas en france puisque
michel voisin à l'assemblée nationale a
identifié un seul événement en mars 2003
qui a conduit à une condamnation par le
tribunal correctionnel de paris
nous aurons donc mis à jour le code de
la défense
nous seront dotés d'un arsenal juridique
nous permettant de traiter pour un
terreau théorique mais nous n'aurons pas
fait reculer la prolifération de nous
savons bien calé pour l'essentiel le
fait d etat d état pour certains au
fonctionnement opaque et peu
démocratique comme la corée du nord ou
le pakistan
des états qui assume tranquillement
devant leur population le fait de s'être
doté de l'armé nucléaire comme le nôtre
nous y reviendrons sans doute mais c'est
là un poids non nous avons été amenés à
débattre à plusieurs reprises je pense
que patiemment au débat qui a été menée
à la suite de la présentation du rapport
d'information de jean pierre chevènement
l'an dernier et si même jean pierre
chevènement
admettez que si le tnt constituaient
effectivement la clé de voûte de l'ordre
nucléaire mondial il n'avait finalement
pas permis d'empêcher la prolifération
nucléaire
ce qui constituait pourtant son
principal objectif théorique
en vérité le premier double d'à côté de
nouveaux observateurs ont pointé le fait
que des liens très étroits existent
entre le nucléaire civil que le tnp
prétend encourager l nucléaire militaire
dont il prétend contenir la diffusion
d'autre part la faiblesse de
l'argumentation selon laquelle certains
états seraient fondés à se doter de ce
type d'armes quand d'autres serait
décidément jugé trop instable ou trop
dangereux pour y avoir accès eux mêmes
nous sommes réellement en difficulté
ce sont des points qui sont largement
débattue la liste est longue des
décisions hasardeuses voire des fautes
qui ont été commises par notre pays en
la matière on se souvient forcément de
la position du président de la
république qui n'avait pas seulement
proposer des rafale à la libye mais
aussi des centrales nucléaires à
vocation civile
je me souviens je me souviens des
commentaires de certains diplomates et
de certains hauts gradés de l'armée il
en frémissent aide avance heureusement
cette proposition ne s'est pas
concrétisé oddo a aussi pointé
l'annoncent d'une volonté de coopération
avec la chine dans le cadre d'un
partenariat global pour la mise au point
d'un réacteur nucléaire de moyenne
puissance du troisième génération ou
encore l'accord de coopération signé le
22 février avec l'arabie saoudite dans
le domaine du nucléaire civil
on doit encore évoqué l'inauguration en
octobre dernier du laser mégajoule
évoqué longuement par michel dubé style
et le développement qui lui est liée
d'armes nucléaires miniaturisés sans
oublier le ralliement de la france au
principe d'une défense antimissile dans
le cadre de l'otan dernier point le
contexte national lui aussi sur
interrogations de député christian
bataille et claude birraux viennent de
faire part de leurs conclusions quant à
l'évaluation du plan national de gestion
des matières et déchets radioactifs dans
leur rapport ils pointent du doigt le
paradoxe de la tranquillité dans le
domaine
r l'anomalie détectée par et df le 1er
février aux conséquences potentielles
sur la sûreté des installations de 34
réacteurs nucléaires en france pose
aussi question
en conclusion comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire à l'occasion de plusieurs
débats ici même à ce sujet je pense que
la seule façon de limiter la
prolifération
cette limite et les arsenaux et de
cesser de vendre des équipements
nucléaires civiles urbi et orbi
nous avons commencé à me proposer à
maintes reprise de commencer par établir
une zone exempte d'armes nucléaires au
moyen-orient
nous avons un devoir d'exemplarité
chiche soyons exemplaires
cessons d'alimenter la machine infernale
en conclusion bien que ce projet de loi
me paraissent assez éloigné de la
réalité concrète du chant nucléaire bien
qu'il ne traite pas contrairement à son
titre de toutes les dimensions de la
lutte contre la prolifération des armes
de destruction massive et de leurs
vecteurs et des matériels connexes
je pense qu il est néanmoins intéressant
tant que signal nous le voterons donc
comme je lui ai annoncé tout à l'heure
il ma chère collègue la discussion
générale et clausule ministre oui merci
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
retrouve le sénat comme nous l'aimons
pour ceux qui aiment la république c'est
à dire un lieu où l'on débat où l'on
s'écoute où l'on peut se retrouver sur
un projet majeur tout en marquant ses
différences c'est exactement le
sentiment que je retire de ce débat
général où les orateurs des différents
groupes ont proposé un vote favorable
nous allons donc vers un vote unanime
tout en indiquant les raisons pour
lesquelles le gouvernement à tout
instant doit faire attention et doit
s'efforcer de faire au mieux je
remercierai
xavier pintât sénateur de gironde parce
qu'il y la reprise avec plus de talent
en plus de compétences que j'en ai à cet
instant mais j'espère le rattraper le
sujet d'ensemble de la lutte contre les
armes de destruction massive
je voudrais dire au ministre de la
défense jean pierre chevènement que j'ai
écouté avec une extrême attention son
intervention parce que comme d'autres
collègues l'ont rappelé il sait outre sa
compétence
je dirais historique s'il accepte cet
adjectif récente à travers sa
communication bien il attirer
l'attention sur non pas des faiblesses
du dispositif mais la nécessité de
l'insérer dans une réflexion plus
soutenue et ne perdre aucune occasion
opportunité il a souligné avec un peu de
malice que le cette ratification était
tardive que nous avions laissé les
années s'écoulent et entre 2004 et 2011
je dois voulait dire que dans d'autres
domaines de ratification de conventions
internationales et notamment directive
européenne je ne pense pas qu'ils
manifestent un zèle d'une activité
totale disons que la france a mûri
progressivement et à travers des
gouvernements les ministres successifs
un texte qui aujourd'hui nous rassemble
mais chacune de ses interventions me
paraît légitime pertinentes et je suis
certain je m'efforcerai avec mes
collaborateurs de les intégrer dans une
réflexion devrait remercier et rachel
mazuir et jacques bertot parce que au
fond nous ont dit vous pouvez voter ce
texte
les choses sont un peu lentes mais
votons le et on progressera qu'ils en
soient à cet instant remercier même de
messine et madame voynet se sont livrés
à un exercice assez assez difficile au
fond à dire qu'ils étaient contre la
politique du gouvernement en général
contre la politique nucléaire en
particulier contre 7
plus jeune plus globalement votre la
politique de la de l'énergie nucléaire
et non pas les unes
nucléaire militaire tout en
reconnaissant qu'il fallait voter le
texte
genre je garderai que la conclusion ils
veulent elles voteront le texte
vos groupes voteront le texte pour ma
part je m'en réjouis c'est au fond un
pas vers une compréhension mutuelle mais
je crois qu'ils ont encore un peu de
chemin à faire et dans le cadre de mes
responsabilités je m'y emploierai je
voudrais dire à andré dulait il a posé
une question extrêmement immédiates et
concrètes sur les sources médicales
nous avons un texte qui est aujourd'hui
en phase finale qui devrait être
présentée par mon collègue ministre de
l'écologie de l'environnement du
développement durable des
infrastructures et du logement
et ce texte je prends l'engagement
devant vous de veiller à ne pas subir
les reproches qui ont été exprimées
d'une façon d'ailleurs tout à fait
raisonnable de d'attendre trop longtemps
et de perdre une occasion de travailler
j'aurais indiqué que ce qui a été engagé
produit des résultats
je ne sais je confesse vrai que je n'ai
pas encore aujourd'hui à cet instant une
compétence suffisante pour vous
convaincre totalement
je reviendrai volontiers sur ce texte
parce qu'il ya eu certes une seule
décision judiciaire mais l'action
européenne et l'action internationale
est saisie en mer le
lemay saisie en particulier de biens à
double usage montre que les la situation
est en train d'évoluer et que les
grandes puissances arrive entraîné
l'immense majorité des pays responsables
vers des politiques d'attention de
contrôle d'isolement et dénonciation de
ce qui en effet auxiliaires d'état 1
certains cherchent à tirer profit de
trafic aux limites de la du trafic
industriels ou du trafic militaires ces
fameux biens à double usage est la
raison pour laquelle à cet instant je ne
suis pas certain de vous convaincre dans
vos doutes mais comme vous voter le
texte
eh bien je me promets de progresser pour
pouvoir vous convaincre la prochaine
fois de toujours le voter comme vous le
faites aujourd'hui mais avec un
enthousiasme que vous ne partagez pas
complètement étranger m'efforcerai de
vous convaincre demain merci monsieur le
ministre nous allons passer à la
discussion des articles du projet de loi
à l'article 1er je ne suis saisi d'aucun
amendements je vais pouvoir faire voter
sur cet article 1er ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption voudront bien
l'exprimer en levant la main
ceux qui sont contre il est adopté sur
les articles 2 à 20 je ne suis saisie
d'aucune demande de prise de parole ni
d'aucun amendements peut-on considérer
que c'est le même vote a bien je vais
donc faire voter sur le proche
l'ensemble sur le projet de loi
ceux qui sont favorables à l'adoption de
ce projet de loi vous dormiez à
l'exprimer
une explication de vote monsieur merci
madame la présidente de m'autoriser à
expliquer en vote qui est déjà acquis
mais que lorsque vous nous avez fait
voter les différents titres et articles
n'y at-il pas nécessité de justifier le
maintien de la suppression de l'article
18 messieurs oui il est supprimé
je fais donc il n'y a pas d'autres
demandes destination de vagues je fait
voter sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
ceux qui sont favorables son adoption
les bons la main merci il est donc
adopté à l'unanimité
l'ordre du jour appelle maintenant la
discussion du projet de loi relatif au
contrôle des importations et des
exportations de matériel de guerre de
matériels assimilés à la simplification
des transferts des produits liés à la
défense dans l'union européenne et aux
marchés de défense et de sécurité dans
la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur gérard longuet
ministre de la défense et des anciens
combattants
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission sera porteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un monde
imprévisible face à des contraintes
budgétaires croissantes
l'europe doit donc être en mesure de
développer des capacités militaires dans
le cadre de la politique de sécurité et
de défense commune qu'elle construit
dans cette construction établir un
marché européen pour les équipements de
défense est donc indispensable
ce projet de loi se propose de
transposer des directives sur les
transferts inter intra communautaires de
produits liés à la défense et sur la
coordination des procédures de passation
de marchés des travaux des marchés de
fournitures des marchés de services dans
les domaines de la défense et de la
sécurité
deux avancées dans ce projet de loi la
première avancée et de fluidifier les
échanges intra communautaires et
harmoniser les modalités de contrôle
étatique pour les entreprises
il y en a des grandes mais il y en a de
très nombreuses beaucoup plus petit
il s'agit de réduire les coûts tu es les
incertitudes juridiques liées à
l'actuelle hétérogénéité des régimes
nationaux dans le domaine des procédures
de contrôle des champs d'application des
délais d'autorisation
le marché européen des produits liés à
la défense est en effet aujourd'hui
fragmenté en 27 régime de contrôle
nationaux pour les états membres
après des entreprises il s'agit de
garantir la sécurité d'un
approvisionnement d'origine européenne
pour répondre aux besoins opérationnels
de leur force je dis bien la sécurité
d'un approvisionnement d'origine
européenne
en ce qui concerne les transferts intra
communautaires le texte propose
d'instaurer un principe de liberté
encadrée du commerce et d'industrie
liberté encadrée donc de supprimer le
dispositif des autorisations
d'importation et de transit
le cadre juridique harmoniser nouveau
reposera sur un dispositif de contrôle à
la fois à priori et a posteriori par le
biais de trois types de licence licence
de transfert évidemment individuel pour
les unes globale et générale
au delà des transferts et intérêts
communautaires
nous avons profité de la transposition
de la directive pour rénover notre
dispositif national de contrôle des
importations et des exportations qui
repose sur des principes qui datent 1939
tirage issement rajeunissement paresse
est souhaitable
le projet de loi propose donc de
remplacer l'actuel système double
autorisation agrément préalable pour
négocier et signer un contrat d'une part
et ensuite autorisation d'exportation
d'autre part par une licence unique qui
fusionnera ces deux autorisations dans
un esprit de simplification
administrative et damon d'harmonisation
avec les procédures en vigueur chez la
plupart de nos partenaires
ce projet de loi créera une licence
générales d'exportation utilisable à
destination de pays jugée suffisamment
sûre et limitativement désigné par un
arrêté mais là les entreprises
bénéficiant d'une licence générales
d'exportation
le projet prévoit également la mise en
place d'un mécanisme de qualification
des entreprises souhaitant utiliser des
licences générales d'exportation et de
certification des entreprises souhaitant
recevoir des produits liés à la défense
donc qualification des entreprises
souhaitant utiliser les licences
d'exportation et certification des
entreprises souhaitant recevoir des
produits liés à la défense afin de
vérifier la fiabilité de l'organisation
interne
le projet prévoit enfin la création d'un
dispositif de contrôle a posteriori avec
la mise en place d'un comité ministériel
du contrôle qui impliquera plusieurs
services du ministère de la défense dans
des opérations de contrôle des
entreprises sur pied
et sur place c'est tout le sens des
amendements gouvernementaux qui ont été
présentés monsieur le président en
commission ces amendements introduisent
trois éléments nouveaux l'habilitation
des agents du ministère de la défense en
charge du contrôle
l'obligation pour les entreprises de
permettre l'accès de ces personnels
habilités et une demande d'avis du
ministre de la défense
préalablement à tout acte de poursuite
envisagée naturellement à un haut niveau
de sécurité sera maintenue toute
autorisation pouvant être suspendu
modifié abroger ou retirer notamment
dans le cas d'un changement du contexte
international rapide et brutale deuxième
avancée que permet ce projet de loi est
de contribuer à l'harmonisation de la
législation communautaire pour favoriser
le développement d'une concurrence plus
loyale au sein de l'union européenne et
introduire plus de transparence dans les
marchés passés par les autres états
membres
c'est l'objectif à l'objectif de la
directive du 13 juillet 2009 relatives
aux marchés de défense et de sécurité
qui vise directive notamment à limiter
l'utilisation massive par certains états
membres de l'article 346 du traité sur
le fonctionnement de l'union européenne
permettant de soustraire des achats
d'armement la concurrence a bien compris
qu'il s'agissait de lutter contre le
protectionnisme national de certains
pays qui excluait nos entreprises de
l'idée même d'accéder à leur marché pour
autant l'ouverture des marchés
qu'organise cette directive est une
ouverture maîtrisée
le texte concerne naturellement la
possibilité d'exclure les marchés
sensibles
il continue également exclure tout
programme de recherche cofinancé avec
d'autres états européens ainsi que ces
phases ultérieures
quand on travaille en état européen en
coopération nous avons cette possibilité
de
regardez un système spécifique enfin il
prévoit de larges possibilités de
sélection des soumissionnaires sur le
fondement des exigences relatives à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en
particulier sur la base de la
localisation des activités sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
mais bien qu'il s'agit d'une ouverture
maîtrisée qui a pour objet de renforcer
de promouvoir de développer une base
industrielle et technologique de défense
européenne projet de loi qui vous est
présentée aujourd'hui rassemble des
dispositions législatives souvent très
techniques qui doivent être adoptées
pour satisfaire aux exigences de
transposition de la directive en droit
français
sachant que l'essentiel de la
transposition se fera ensuite par voie
réglementaire
il prévoit de modifier l'ordonnancé du 6
juin 2005 relative aux marchés non
soumis au code des marchés publics afin
d'assurer la cohérence de ces
dispositions avec c'est que celle du
code des marchés publics
cette modification permet en outre la
prise en compte de la définition
communautaire de la sous-traitance et
l'introduction des mesures nécessaires
pour fermer certains marchés aux
opérateurs économiques non
ressortissants de l'union européenne
il prévoit également de modifier le code
de justice administrative pour y insérer
les dispositions relatives au recours
prévu par la directive pour les marchés
de défense et de sécurité c'est normal
c'est de l'harmonisation texte initial
proposé par le gouvernement était sans
doute perfectible
nous avons accueilli avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé seul président la
proposition du président de ronde
travailler à son amélioration bénéfices
l'a mené de la réforme constitutionnelle
et modestie du gouvernement si celle de
mon prédécesseur réalisme aussi sur la
base de débats fructueux et constructif
avec les services du ministère avec les
industriels de la défense avec la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et les forces armées de votre
assemblée
un amendement a reçu le plein soutien du
gouvernement
la nouvelle rédaction de l'article 5 qui
résulte de l'adoption de cet amendement
en commission
exploite au mieux les différentes
possibilités qu'offre la directive
d'encadrer les modalités d'ouverture
sur des marchés à la concurrence sans
aller jusqu'à là net affirmation d'une
préférence communautaire qui ne serait
pas conforme au droit communautaire
chacun ici le sait le texte s'appuie sur
la directive pour permettre aux services
acheteurs de définir si un marché est
ouvert ou non à la concurrence extra
communautaires le service acheteur peut
fonder sa décision sur l'analyse d'un
ensemble de critères explicites et dans
le projet de loi parmi lesquels figurent
madame voynet n'est plus là parce qu'il
y a en effet un volet écologique mais là
je vous parlerai des impératifs de
sécurité d'information et
d'approvisionnement de la préservation
des intérêts de la défense et de la
sécurité de l'état de l'intérêt de
développer la base industrielle et
technologique de défense européenne des
objectifs de développement durable
toujours bienvenu en l'espèce et d
exigence de réciprocité
le texte donne également les moyens au
service h heure des cartes et une offre
ou un candidat dont les capacités
techniques ne serait pas à niveau pour
exécuter les marchés ou pour assurer la
maintenance des équipements faisant
l'objet du dit marché ses capacités
techniques peuvent notamment être
apprécié au regard de l'implantation
géographique de l'équipement technique
du personnel ou encore des sources
d'approvisionnement dont dispose le
candidat ainsi en s'appuyant sur des
exigences relatives à la sécurité de
l'information et la sécurité des
approvisionnements les services
acheteurs peuvent vérifier la pertinence
de l'ensemble des composantes d'une
offre et en particulier les capacités
techniques des sous traitants utiliser
nouvelle bien que nous nous dotons à
travers ce texte d'un dispositif qui
permet d'écarter ce que l'on appelle
dans ses échanges commerciaux et
industriels bien spécifiques
les faux nez au terme du processus de
transposition de ces deux directives
adoptées par le conseil et le parlement
européen lorsque la france assurait la
présidence de l'union européenne je vous
le rappelle je pense profondément que
nous avons atteint le bon équilibre
entre l'ouverture à la concurrence
européenne de nos marchés de défense et
la protection des intérêts de notre base
industrielle de défense
je tiens donc à saluer à nouveau le
travail remarquable accompli par la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des armées
la haute assemblée avec laquelle nous
travaillons dans un parfait esprit de
confiance et de dialogue
nous avons ensemble à travers l'adoption
de ce texte
l'opportunité de franchir une étape
essentielle dans la construction de
l'europe de la défense que nous appelons
tous dans notre pays de nos voeux c'est
pourquoi je compte sur votre soutien
pour faire adopter ce texte au service
des industries de défense de notre pays
merci monsieur ministre 1
la parole est à monsieur josselin de
rohan rapporteur de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
permettez moi à mon tour de joindre mes
félicitations tardive à celle de mes
collègues vous présenter mes voeux de
réussite dans votre action et vous dire
combien nous avons confiance en vous
pour continuer la coopération confiante
que nous avions avec vos prédécesseurs
le parlement européen et le conseil ont
adopté en 2009 le paquet défense qui est
un ensemble formé de deux directives et
d'une commune communication de la
commission européenne de 2007 intitulé
stratégie pour une industrie européenne
de la défense plus forte et plus
compétitive
les deux directives sont la directive
2009 43 100e du 6 mai 2009 simplifiant
les conditions de transfert de produits
liés à la défense à la communauté plus
communément dénommé transferts intra
communautaires tsl et la directive 2009
86e du 13 juillet 2009 relative à la
coordination des procédures de passation
de certains marchés travaux de
fournitures et de services par des
pouvoirs adjudicateurs ou entités
adjudicatrices dans les domaines de la
défense et de sécurité et modifiant les
directives 2004 17 c e et 2004 18 ce e
plus communément dénommé marchés publics
de défense et de sécurité les
communications de 2007 pose l'équation
fondatrice selon laquelle la politique
européenne de sécurité et de défense
rebaptisé par le traité de lisbonne
politique de sécurité défense commune ne
peut se passer d'une base industrielle
et technologique de défense forte en
europe et que seule une baie ide
compétitive que donner à l'europe les
moyens de concevoir et de fabriquer les
équipements de défense de manière
autonome
un coût abordable la première directive
de mai 2009 simplifie les conditions des
transferts de produits liés à la défense
au sein de l'espace économique européen
le être transposée avant le 30 juin de
cette année la seconde directives de
juillet 2009 harmonise les règles
m
des code des marchés publics des états
membres pour permettre une meilleure
transparence et plus de concurrence dans
le processus d'achat des équipements de
défense
elle doit être transposée avant le 21
août 2011
ensemble ces textes marque un tournant
par rapport au régime dérogatoire des
règles du marché unique qui régit la
production et l'achat d'armement ce
régime fondé sur l'article 296 du traité
des communautés européennes devenu le
nouvel article 346 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
permet à chaque état d'éviter de
recourir à la concurrence chaque fois
qu'il estime que ses intérêts essentiels
en matière de sécurité sont en jeu
l'interprétation extensive qui en avait
été faite avait permis à certains états
européens de mettre leur industrie de
défense à l'abri de toute concurrence
européenne cette utilisation abusive a
conduit à fermer des marchés civils sous
prétexte de préservation des intérêts de
sécurité ce qui a généré un contentieux
naissant devant la cour de justice des
communautés européennes
face au risque d'extension
jurisprudentielle du domaine de la libre
concurrence
les industriels européens ont milité en
faveur d'une réglementation plus clair
c'est ce qui a donné naissance aux
directives du paquet défense qui ont été
finalisés pendant la présidence de
l'union française levure est prégnante
française de l'union européenne au
second semestre 2008
si le droit issu des négociations
préserve les spécificités des marchés de
défense et de sécurité d'une application
mécanique des règles du marché
il n'impose pas formellement une clause
de préférence communautaire vous l'avez
dit pourtant l'émergence d'une
authentique bits et des oeufs suppose
l'existence d'une préférence
communautaire vis-à-vis des opérateurs
économiques de pays tiers grands marchés
et de l'application du principe de
réciprocité entre états européens à
l'intérieur du grand marché c'est dire
l'importance de cette transposition
il nous revient en tant que législateur
de trouver un juste équilibre entre
d'une part une salutaire ouverture à la
concurrence qui stimulera l'innovation
améliorera la compétitivité des
entreprises et permettra aux états de
réduire les coûts d'acquisition des
biens d'équipement et d'autre part une
trop grande ouverture qui détruirait bon
nombre d'entreprises et nous rendrait
trop dépendants d'armes fabriquées par
d'autres pour assurer notre propre
défense de ce point de vue le texte qui
nous était proposé par le gouvernement
nous a semblé perfectible et notre
commission a effectué une modification
du texte de l'article 5 pour l'article
37 3 de l'ordonnancé du 6 juin 2005
je souhaiterais dans le cadre de cette
discussion générale faire un certain
nombre d'observations
la première est que la production et le
commerce des armes de guerre et de leurs
munitions ne pourront jamais être
considérée comme une production et un
commerce ordinaire forger des armes de
guerre pour les armées n'est pas
produire des biens de consommation pour
le public en autoriser l'exportation est
un acte politique
importé des armes suppose d'avoir
confiance en l'état qu'il est fourni et
dans sa volonté de poursuivre les
approvisionnements si le pire devait se
produire un état peut-être souverain
sans pour autant produire d'armes et
aucun état souverain digne de ce nom ne
peut rester indifférent à la production
ni au commerce des armes de ces armes
est du reste les questions se posent un
état peut-il disposer une défense
crédible sans base industrielle de
défense autonome
pour nous cette dans cette base
industrielle autonome constitue la lune
des conditions de notre indépendance
d'autres pays en europe des voyeurs ont
apporté à cette question une réponse
plus nuancé soit qu'il n'ait pas les
moyens d'entretenir une base
industrielle autonome soit qu'ils s'en
remettent à des états tiers pour se
procurer les armements dont ils ont
besoin soit qu'ils pensent qu'une
alliance tels que l'otan assurera leur
défense à leur place il est pourtant
évident l'industrie défense et l'un des
moteurs de la recherche du développement
économique et de l'emploi dans tous les
pays qui en possèdent une
la r&d en matière de défense est
particulièrement innovante sépare
construction une r&d de rupture
puisqu'il s'agit de réaliser des armes
important un avantage décisif sur les
autres et donc de mettre en oeuvre des
technologies qui n'existe
pas elle s'oppose en cela à l'air et des
civils qui est plus souvent incrémentale
c'est pour cette raison de la r&d
militaire est stratégiquement importante
que les programmes d'armement sont en
règle générale plus long et plus coûteux
que prévu
beaucoup d'innovations viennent de la
r&d militaire et profite à l'ensemble de
l'économie
ce qui conduit souvent les pays
importateurs d'armes de guerre a demandé
des compensations industrielles ou
offset afin d'acquérir des compétences
industrielles qu'ils n'ont pas et qu'ils
recherchent dans des secteurs jugés par
eux stratégique
en second lieu la présente transposition
permet une indéniable modernisation de
notre droit
ces directives comme la plupart des
directives européennes laisse une marge
de manoeuvre importante aux pouvoirs
législatifs nationaux
cette marche peut être utilisé afin de
réexaminer la législation nationale de
moderniser les procédures et de se
débarrasser des archaïsmes en
s'inspirant des meilleures pratiques
européennes c'est ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement
petit tas de la transposition de la
directive tic en remettant à plat le
système législatif actuel lui
substituant un nouveau dispositif
beaucoup plus efficace en simplifiant
les procédures d'autorisation et un
instaurant un contrôle a posteriori
efficace il nous faut combiner une
réforme de ces procédures avec le strict
respect du texte de la directive de
manière à assurer la sécurité juridique
de la transposition nous observons aussi
que directives du paquet défense ont été
élaborés avant la crise financière et
que l'on peut y voir l'avancée d'une
europe de la défense davantage orientée
vers les marchés que vers les états
reflétant la théorie anglaise dit de la
baisse value foreman et les directives
du paquet défense n'en est elle pour
seul effet que nous permettent
d'acquérir nos armes à moindre coût ce
serait déjà un avantage à ne pas
dédaigner
dans un contexte budgétaire déjà
contraint mais c'est directive ne
permettent pas à elles seules de
réaliser l'europe de la défense la
logique qui les sous-tend devrait
permettre de disposer de bases
équitables de concurrence entre
industriels européens
cela ne suffira pas pour autant à
construire une base
industriel et technologique de défense
européenne forte et autonome il faudrait
pour cela non seulement l'affirmation de
la préférence communautaire et la
régulation des conditions de marché
c'est-à-dire une politique de l'offre
mais aussi une politique de la demande
qui suppose l'harmonisation des besoins
des programmations par les états majors
des pays de l'union et une harmonisation
de l'effort de défense dans chacun des
pays qui la composent la force de
l'industrie américaine vient de ce
qu'elle dispose d'un marché intérieur
qui non seulement protégé par le buy
american act mais aussi vaste et profond
or la dimension du marché américain des
armements tient non seulement à
l'importance des sommes qui sont
consacrés mais aussi à l'uniformisation
des besoins au sein d'une même armée les
industriels américains fabrique des
blindés des frégates des avions de
combat pour répondre aux besoins d'un
seul état fédéré à la différence de
l'europe
la puissance de l'industrie comme de
leur r&d leur permet de s'assurer des
avantages incomparables à l'exportation
et de concurrencer durement sur les
marchés mondiaux leurs compétiteurs
européens
tant que l'europe ne sera pas capable
d'harmoniser la demande de mettre fin
ray segmentation de ces industries de
l'armement ou d'organiser une
coopération efficace entre ces
entreprises de défense
la lutte demeurera inégale c'est assez
dire que le préalable à la réalisation
de l'europe de la défense est une
volonté politique forte des états
membres la coopération
franco-britannique initiée par les
traités signés à londres en novembre
dernier marque véritablement une
nouvelle étape dans la construction de
l'europe de la défense
elle constitue une approche très
différente des précédentes qui marque
une véritable rupture en ce qu'elle
constitue une démarche pragmatique et
concrète à une architecture globale est
mal assurée des programmes d'équipement
précis est financé à des velléités ou
des réalisations mince elle peut être le
prélude aux coopérations renforcées
prévue par le traité de lisbonne qui
seuls peuvent faire progresser la psdc
et lui donner de la consistance
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi
cette séance si vous souhaitez la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr nous
reviendrons bien entendu sur les
premiers pas de gérard longuet en tant
que ministre de la défense dans notre
édition de 19h à très bonne fin de
journée à tous